ça y est il est parti je CIS que déjà
Mo
bon mais là il faudrait qu'on soit à sa
qu'on soit à sa gauche parce que si sa
droite on a pas les on a pas du tout l'
ou
plus plus
cont plus
devanti
je vois plus
çaangux0 alors
voe ça
voilà c'est joli
ça je sais pas comment faire je sais pas
comment
tu mets l'avion tu mets ton avion en bas
de l'image tu vois
etour sur ta droite qu' aille un peu
plus droite vousz un peu plus sur la
droite c'est
tu bien pas
commentire un peu'il
plat
cont
plusut
plus
dem si vous pouvez descendre plus
B
pas
ok on faire la même chose s'il vous
plaît ok on fait 180° la même chose mê
s'il vous
plaît par la
droite
vousz Sénégal 323 bien contacter Dakar
maintenant
éng 323 on va contacter dakard sur 12.5
non mais c'est aucun intérêt tu vois
d'accord avec moi ah ben non ou ouais
parce que à mon avis il doit re un peu
avec son de voler doucement il doir un
peu on est 6 im ou
ou
compr pasù on
est s'il vous
plaît
toujours
L
contuxiger ben ouais mais là devant tu
vois
village mon avis fa aller plus plus à
l'est
encore des cordon làbas plus grand B ben
allons-y allons-y tu le diriges ten
occupe on va on va aller plus à l'est il
y a des cordons de N plus importants
donc 90°gr à gauche s'il vous plaît
c'est bon ça qu'est-ce que tu en penses
ouais 90 deg gauche on va prendre un
autre cordon de plus important est-ce
que tu crois qu'on a intért qui peut
aller sil veut aller plus aller plus
vite sentir plus à l'aise
eter peuter plus vite le anglais je peux
dire tour
s beau c'est Jol
OK
PvE prendre un tout pe à droite 10 20 de
à dro pour rester
sur tu vois son nombre de
position unité on voudrait le
roulageou point d'arrêt 05 le vent
07° désolé mais il faut que je sorte
pour le c'est joli l'avion là qui ve
son c'est joli ça ah oua c'est beau ça
c'est magnifique c'est pas mal vous al
là ouais c'est
mie négatif on va décoller en 05 ensuite
on va faire un virage à gauche et on va
faireie de faire son faire son tout seul
on a de longueur de
plan on a tourné combien de temp
là dire non sur ce plan là là je sais
pas une minute une minute ça fait donc 2
minutes c'est Ji avec son bre là faire
un plan de sonbre qui se déplace partout
sur les d c'est
joli05
AR va faire le point sur son
n son nombre est flou je suis flou
donc le sable est net lui donc c'est bon
c'est pas
terrible para plus n y a 10 secondes ou
du plan
non c'est la
lumière un
truc pareili
c'est
vrai
2h10 7 25 935 le plan précédent en fait
il fait plus de 2 minutes donc il fait 4
minutes donc c'est
bon contrôler là sur la
mémoire on le fait aller à droite là sur
le blanc là attends regardemi une autre
valeur
ouais il y a pas d'ombre ouais bon
écoute il est trop le mec hein oublie
hein est-ce qu'il peut descendre dem
lui'il peut descendre encore un peu me
demande si vous pouvez descendre un
petit
peu
actellement à 600 m 200 pied ça fait 200
pied tu divises par 3 c'est ça non tu
divises par 2 tu rajoutes 10 % ah ou m
20 m sol je demand tout à l'heure je dis
d'ut
voilà là tuas l're tu vois voilà tu vois
là tu as l're là là tu l'as bien l're
voilà
ouis mais c'est
pas ou on va le faire on
faireer c'est très bien comme ça c'est
génial vu que c'est vachement bien et s
pouvez aller se déplacer sur cordon de
qui est à droite voilà ouis mais là il
va s'arrêter le cordon de
lune qu'on pass reprendre dansre sens
voilà dis que c'est vachement bien c'est
exactement ce qu' nous faut tu lu dis
c'est super pour l'altitude là c'est
beaucoup mieux pour
nous on peut pas M là on a de on est
dans c'est ça c'est ça qui nous fa voilà
on ça sur le cordon c'est top tu vois
voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà demand
qu'il nous fasse la même chose sur un
cordon c'est formidable alors faudrait
qu'on fasse la même chose sur un cordon
d'une et ce serait vraiment formidable
donc si vous pouvez prendre 90°
droiteter peonter il peonter le temps
qu'on c le plan si vous voulez remonter
un petit peu il y a pas de problème donc
90 deg à droite si vous
pouvez on
toujours pour moi je peux me reposer 2
secondes pour regarder là tu vois c'est
plus
facile orte
les le de la
plage ah il est trop il est trop il est
trop trop trop
trop écoute fais fais le large avec son
n tout à l'heure parce que sinon on va
rien
comprendre
pas ouais c'est joli ça on tout c'est
joli
plusiteim
PE les d'un froun tout droit sur le
cordon c'est
nickel on est pas très très beau sur le
sur l'image on pas beaucoup un joli
cordon
là arrive sur la
PL on Demand ce que
c'est super
beau
oui ou c'est bien c'est bien comme ça
allez
on bien sur un cordon est-ce qu'il
pas sur la droite non c'est joli voil
voilà voilà super on y arrive génial
regarde voil
regardéopère pour de
super super ok génial gnial super
regarde W regarde om qui se B
W
magnifique disli que c'est bien pe-ê
Franck pardon y excuse-moi il pe dire
que c'est bien c'est très bien merci si
vous arrivez à voler un tout petit peu
plus bas ce sera vraiment super voilà
merci beaucoup il y a plus de cordonuss
c'est un petit peu oh c'est génial
ça c'est beau ça ouais voilà ce que je
voulais c'est beau excuse-moi y
tu
un tout petit peu à gauche pour
reprendre bien le cord léèrement à ga
merci
beaucoup
ça voil bien
super bien voil c'est
génialuche un petit texte
c'est beau c'est beau ça je su
ravi l'OM qui bouge qui va descendre
comme une
F dans 20 secondes on aura 4 minutes sur
ce
plan
tu peux t'élargir un peu qu'est-ce tu as
envie de faire là je faire
l'ombre c'est marrant c'est marrant ça
c'est bien c'est super ça ouais
génial génial génial on dirait un oiseau
qui vole et
qui il peux le mettre un peu sur la non
c'est plus ça veut écrire à côté je te
laisse faire là
limite il est descendu là il est remonté
un peu voir Mo bien
ou est il il est remonté tu
vois prends son avec prends son avece
beau ok ça rien à voir qu pas
l'ombreok d'accord ou ou c'est bien
d'avoir l'ombre devant je trouve enc
voil c'est vachement mieux comme ça
comme ça on demande ce que c'est comme
sil avait un pilot devant lui tu vois un
poisson pilote
ouais c'est
génial il serait bien c'est de le faire
maintenant tout à l'heure un plan il
soit en largeur et non pas en hauteur
enin qu'on remplisse le cadre tu vois
donc c'est bien ça regarde comme c'est
beau c'est drle on dirait vraiment un
oiseau qui vole qui suit le vent encore
une minute et on change de
cassette qu'on fe en vitesse normale ou
pas ça moi je te suggère de faire au
moins une bonne prise en vitesse normale
au cas
où
dit qu' remonter un petit peu OK